There's another piece to URLs I'd like to show you--
and this is the final piece we'll talk about right now--
and that's called, the "port".
When you make a Web request to a Server, this is the host.
This is the name of the machine
or the location of the machine you're requesting.
In order to make an Internet connection, you need 2 things.
You need: 1) the address of the machine, which is represented by the host
and 2) you also need a port.
And, by default, the port equals 80.
If you want to use a different port,
you can include it in the URL
between the host and the path, separated by a colon.
And in this case, we'll be making a request on port 8000.
Get used to this URL because this will be
your local development URL for a lot of this course--
and, actually, for a lot of your career as a Web developer.
You're constantly accessing your local machine
and you're probably doing it on something other than port 80.
There are even more parts to a URL,
but they're not particularly relevant to us right now.
They'll come up as we go.
Let's do one final quiz about URLs, before we move on.
What I'd like you to do is take this URL
and identify its main parts:
host, protocol, fragment, query, and port.